Donald Trump jr. released a series of
emails showing he actively tried to
collaborate with the Russians before the
election yeah yeah when he heard this
Donald Trump said good luck trying to
connect me to Donald Trump jr.
now this is cool Donald Trump jr. is
being represented by homophony who has
defended four New York crime families
yes that's a true story
yeah I didn't make that up that's real
so now the lawyer has updated his resume
to say defended five New York crime
you know I'm getting laughs here I
thought maybe this would start to look a
little better but not White House chief
of staff
Reince Priebus has dismissed the latest
Trump Russia story as quote a nothing
burger yeah a nothin burger when
questioned about his really strange
choice of words he explained my name is
Reince Priebus let's say I'm doing a
magic trick for kids this section over
here
a new study just found that Republican
health care bill the Republican health
care bill has the same approval rating
as Nickelback and herpes that's true
that's true yeah yeah
when asked to comment the herpes virus
said hey don't lump me in with those
guys they asked the herpes virus for
kaan of course they did sure what hey
did ya over the weekend an elderly woman
flashed her chest at Dodger Stadium on
the jumbotron it's all part of a new
baseball tradition the seventh-inning
stretch marks
are we doing nobody good here yeah I'm
sorry folks you either laugh or that one
of you don't you don't applaud it well
oh that was really something yes gotta
mention this got a man you just got to
do it
United Airlines is under fire for
destroying a man's custom-made $42,000
wheelchair yeah so part of their new
slogan United Airlines
walk it off [ __ ]
you
you